NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
こんにちは。UITの玉田です。今回もUIT INSIDEを始めたいと思います。
UIT INSIDEは、ユーザーインターフェースとテクノロジーを愛する開発者のためのポッドキャストです。え、今回は、はい、 えっと、2023年の、えー、新卒の方を、えー、3人お呼びしました。で、え、今回、その3人、えっと、丸岡さんと板井さんとテオさんの3人をお呼びしてるんですけども、ま、今回は、
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
ま、座談会ということで、これまでやってきたこととか、今後の抱負みたいなことについて、ま、これから話していければなと思います。それでは、よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
はい、
では、まずは自己紹介ですかね。入った順にします？ テオさん、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
じゃあ話しましょう。
えっと、2022年の秋入社として入ってきたドイツ出身のテオドアシュタイナーと申しますと。会社ではテオと呼ばれています。で、 えっと、担当しているプロダクトとしては、OAだから、公式アカウントのクーポンとOA list、それは公式アカウントが見つけられるプロダクトが、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
えっと、メインになっています。これまでやっていたことについてですけど、僕は背景が完全に文系になっていて、 それでもweb開発に興味を持って、2年前ぐらいにSvelteっていうフロントエンドフレームワークが見つかって、で、それにすごい興味を持って、そのコミュニティとかに入った経由で、
えっと、LINEに入社ができました。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そうですね、テオさんはSvelteの人というイメージが
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Svelte推しです。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
また後で話を聞いてみようと思います。よろしくお願いします。では、どちらに。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
はい、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
いや、一緒だから。一緒です。はい、
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
23卒の春の入社で入りました。大阪出身の板井俊樹と申します。
で、現在取り組むプロジェクトはLINEスキマニにというスキマバイトを探すサービスのフロントエンド部分の開発をしています。
でま、もっと詳しく言うと、ま、スキマニは個別でネイティブアプリを作成しているんですが、僕はこのネイティブアプリ回りの開発を担当しています。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
で、これまでやってたことについてなんですが、僕は情報系じゃなくて、元々機械系出身で、でま、機械系やったんですけど、 そういう便利なサービスとかものが好きで、 そういうwebサービスとか作ってみたいなっていうことで、前から、ちょっと情報系によって、個人開発で、日程調整、LINEの上で動く、ま、LINEの日程調整とはちょっと違う、時間単位で調整できるような日程調整サービスを作って、
で、結構いろんなユーザーに使われて、その流れでウェブ開発楽しいなっていう流れでLINEに入りました。よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
よろしくお願いします。日程調整、調整さんとかめっちゃ有名ですけど、あれ、なかなかその、あの、 使い勝手が。とかもめっちゃ気にされてるのかな。とか、そこらへんとかも結構あれですよね。フロントエンド。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
調整さんをLINE上で動くようにして、もうちょいUIUXをちょっと改良した版みたいな感じです。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
いいですね。いやもう、ぜひLINE自体のUIを改善していきましょう。じゃあ、はい、よろしくお願いします。お願いします。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
23卒の丸岡と申します。よろしくお願いします。
と、僕は今は、えっと、プロダクトとしては、LINEギフトの、えっと、フロントエンドの開発を担当しています。で、 その中では、主に、今は、ショップ出品者向けのcmsの開発だったり、あと、本体のLINEギフトの方では、えっと、アクセシビリティの改善とか、主に担当しています。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
はい、えっと、これまでやっていたこととしては、 そうですね、えっと、インターンだったり、バイトだったりで、結構、ウェブ開発というか、フロントのの開発とかしていたんですけど、大学の方は、結構、あんまりウェブ開発には馴染みがない。馴染みがないというか、関係がないところで、 学部の時は深層学習を使った、なんか超解像モデルみたいなものを扱っていたり、あとは、大学院では、僕がそもそもプログラミング始めたきっかけになったのがビットコインなんですけど、
ブロックチェーンとかにもちょっと興味があって、結局実装したことはないんですけど、ブロックチェーンに関係する研究とかをちょっとしてました。
で、ま、そうですね。結局、なんやかんやま、フロントエンドの開発してる時が楽しいなっていうところで、えっと、まあ、LINEでフロントエンド開発 をましていきたいなっていう部分で入社しました。はい、以上です。よろしくお願いします。よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
確かに大学でそのウェブフロントエンドを本格的にやるってことはない。あ まああるかもしれないけど、ないかもしれないってなると、やっぱり何らかの、まあ興味があってフロント、ウェブフロントエンドなのかなっていうところ、まあそこらへんとか 聞けると確かに嬉しいですね。また、じゃあ後で話をお聞きしましょう。よろしくお願いします。よろしくお願いします。
では、えーっと、そうですね、まあ、座談会なんで、あの、お互い、あの、質問とかも、はい、 何かあればっていう感じなんですけど、まずは、そうですね、えっと、まあちょっと話出ましたけれども、あの、ウェブフロントエンドをわざわざ選んだ理由っていうのは、これ、私が結構、ま、恒例で 聞いてる感じにはなってるんですけど、なんか何か理由があって選んだのかなっていう
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
ところがあるかなと思いますので、まー、どういったきっかけとか、なんかこういう、例えばReact、Vueみたいな、そういったところの、まあ技術的なトピックとか、なんか興味があれば聞いてみればいいなと思います。どうしましょう。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
そうです、多分1番変わった技術使っているので、僕から話します。えっと、私の親が、えっと、ドイツでビアガーデンを運営していて、で、そのビアガーデンのために、えっと、ウェブサイトが必要に
で、それで、なんか、その、 エージェンシーとかに、その、その、ウェブサイト作り、作りを任せたら、かなり高くなるのかなと思って、 なんか、自分でその、ウェブサイト作ってみようかなって思ったんですけど、なんか、最初は、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
それは、HTMLとバニラJavaScriptで頑張ろうと思ったんですけど、その レストランの規模ほど小さいウェブサイトでも、その、バニラCSS、HTMLとJavaScriptだけだと、かなりまあ複雑なコードベースになるなっていうことに気づきました。で、それで色々と調べたら、 なんか、正直に言うと、そのReact、かなりレベル高いなと思って、なんかそれ、文系の僕にはとても理解できないなと思ったら、なんかYouTubeでそのSvelteを作ったリッチハリスさんの発表にぶつかって。
で、あ、これなら僕にも書けそうだなと思ったのが、えっと、ウェブのフロントエンドに入ったきっかけですかねー
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
なんかもう、いきなり、や、やばい、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ドイツっぽい
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
あれですね。日本で例えたら、実家の寿司屋のサイトを
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
たまたまSvelte、Vueとかもあったと思うんですけど
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
そうですね。あのVueも一応考えてたんですけど、そのSvelteの、なんかその、コンパイラを使っているから、ビアガーデンのウェブサイトだとパフォーマンスそこまで大切じゃないと思いますけど、その、 やっぱりそういう技術者の心として、なんかいいパフォーマンスのサイト作りたいなと思って。それで、そのコンパイラを使った制度で、とても軽いJavaScriptバンドルがアウトプットされるのがいいなって思いました
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
なんかさい、最初の選んだフレームワークってあれですよね、ポケモンみたいに最初のポケモンなんだみたいな、そういうところあると思うんですけど、や Svelte、しかも結構前ですよね
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
えーと、2年半前が、あー、ですよね。Svelteのバージョンスリーが出たばかりの時期
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
でした。あ、バージョン3、じゃま、一応リリースはしてからは経ってるんですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
そうですね。意外とSvelteも今になって歴史が長いです。多分最初のリリースが2016年だった
だと思います。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
すごい
ユニークな入り方ですね。いやめっちゃ面白い。2人はどうですか。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
僕、あ、元々昔からその、便利なサービスとかもとかが好きで、そういうものを 小学生ぐらいからずっと作りたいなと思ってて、でもその知識なかったんで、便利なものって 機械。って感じで思って、大学では機械系にうん、入ったんですが、思ったより機械系って、機械って名前入ってるけど、エンジンの開発とか流体力学とか、そういうユーザーから
若干距離が遠いようなもの作りが対象で、ちょっとなんか違うなって若干思いながら研究とかはしていました。で、その時に同時にサークル、250人ぐらいのサークルで社内SEみたいなことずっとやってて、 ちょっとしたウェブで作ったりとか、あと社内、社内じゃないサークル内の情報共有システムみたいなやつを、元々あった、古い、え、ホームページをスラックに置き換えたりとか、まそういうことをずっとやってて、で、こういうサービス作ったら、まおも自分も楽しいし、あと、こう、いろんなユーザーに使ってもらったり、
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
その、楽しいなと思って、もうちょいユーザーとの距離が近いところで物作りがしたいなと思って、ま大学院でちょっと情報系に移って、 で、そこで、まその大学院の、ま研究、HCI系、ヒューマンコンピューターインタラクションって、ま人間との、機械との間の、繋ぐような研究をしつつ、そこで、自分の個人開発とかして、やっぱりフロントエンド楽しいなと思って、フロントエンドエンジニア選びました。反動反動。ちょっとあれだけど、ユーザーから距離が遠いもの作りをしてて、もうちょいフラストレーションが溜まって、もうちょいフロントに近づきたいなっていう思いでフロントエンドエンジニアを選びました。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
なるほど。多分私と近いかもしれないですね。そうですね。私まそ、あの、プログラミング始めたのは大学からなんですけど、そうですよね、なんかまあ、個人開発をしてて、 そうですね、フロントエンドとしてちゃんと最初に作ったのは、なんかgifアニメーションみたいなのを、あの、ブラウザ上で作るっていうやつを 昔作って、で、まあ、それぐらいからですかね、フロントエンド面白いなっていう。いや、共感すごい。めっちゃ共感できる。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
元々は情報系。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そうですね、大学部は情報系でしたね。ま、でも、そんなに、あんまりウェブはとは近くはないんですよ。
最初C言語やって、で、あのー、その後、Javaで、最終的になんかコンパイラー作るみたいな感じになるんですけど、webは、 まあ、せいぜい、なんかPerlのなんか、みたいな、そうそうな感じだったんで、JavaScriptとかも授業とかでは出てこなかったし。そうなんですよね。あんまり実際そんなに変わらないかもしれない。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
なるほど。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
はい。あ、いいですか。
僕は、きっかけみたいなところだと、僕もプログラミング始めたのが、ま、大学生入ってからなんですけど、なんか元々は、えっと、ま、全く縁がなくて、 なんか、友達のがやってる仮想通貨のウェブメディアみたいなところがあって、そこで、なんかライターとして記事とかを書いてたんです、元々。
で、なんかその記事書く中で、例えば、なんか、ブロックチェーンの仕組みを解説するみたいなのがあった時に、もうわからなすぎて。で、ただ、それをなんか理解しようとすると、結局、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
なんか、ソースコードとかをにたどり着いて、でも、これも何も読めないなみたいな状態になって、で、そこで、そもそもプログラミングとか できないと、解説とかできるわけないよなみたいな感じで思って、で、プログラミングの勉強をしたいなって、そこ、その辺で思い始めたんですけど。
で、ただ、それをこう、ま、その友達とかに相談した時に、なんか、じゃあ、一旦、うちで
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そのメディアの開発自体をやって、プログラミング自体を学んでから、そういう、ま、シープラとかで実装してる部分とかをなんか読みに行ったらいいんじゃない。みたいな感じになって、そこで、初めてこう始めたのが webフロントエンドだったんですけど、なんかそれが思ってた以上になんか楽しくて、 なんかそもそもの1番最初の目的だったとことか全然忘れて、そもそもなんかフロントエンドのなんかこう作って、ユーザーのなんかリアクションがあったり、こういう機能めっちゃ便利。みたいな部分とか、
なんかそういう、やっぱユーザーとの距離が近くて、こう自分が作ったものが目に見えやすくて、みたいな部分が1番ウェブフロントで、ま、楽しくて、なんかこれ1番やりたいなっていう風に思って選びました。はい。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
いや、
じゃあ、あれなんですかね、あの、JavaScriptの勉強は、独学。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そうですね、一応、その、そこにも、開発というか、ま、CTOみたいな形で、 開発してる、ま、友達なんですけど、友達がいて、に、こう、教わりつつ、みたいな感じで、本読んで、ま、独学みたいな感じです。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ワクチンの、えっと、ポータルサイトだと思いますけど、なんか、web3を使ってる技術とかも、それを使って、開発してきましたか。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
いや、そういう、 なんか、それの、もっと前のフェーズというか、の時点で、その時はほんとに、ビットコインっていうワードが世に出始めたぐらいの時期だったんで、 ほんとに、そもそもブロックチェーンの仕組みでどうなってるのとか、そういうのを解説するみたいなところでやってて、web3とかが、そういうワードがまず出始める結構前でしたね、その頃は
大学1年、2年ぐらいだから6年前とか
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
うんうん、はい
私も大学院時代ぐらいにそうなんですよね。ちょっとプチブームがあって、ビットコインを買ったりしてる人が。
いや、そう、私も絶対その時に買えばよかった。 とんでもない金額に。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
いや、でも逆になんかその時に買って、メモリースティックとかに入れて、そのメモリースティックどこかでなくした人とかいますよね
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そっか、そうですよね。その頃は、なんか、保存っていうか、なんか、そう、結構、あれですよね。ほんとになんて言うんですか。ギークというか。うんうん。
いや、うん、とっつきづらい感じはあったけど、結構早い段階から。興味があったんですね。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
はい。結局、ブロックチェーンの実装とかは、実際、し、してはないんですけど、その前にwebフロントに引っかかって、 そこが楽しかった。はい。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
なるほどはい。ま、でも、あれですね、インターフェイスっていうか、そういうのが好きなんだなって。うん、面白いなとか。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
なんか魔法みたいですよね。なんか、コードを書いて見れるものが出てくる。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
かっこいいめちゃめちゃ
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
言い回しがおしゃれ。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
私たちは、それちょっと使わせてもらいます。魔法使い。
まあ、もうちょっとあれですかね。具体的な技術とかはもしありますかね。それ。そんなに。あんまり興味とかは。2人はあのSvelte大好きとかではなく。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
そうですね、技術。普通に技術が好きなのは。ま、Reactから僕は。入ったんで。基本React周りの知識。
周り興味があって。最近で言うとサーバーコンポーネント周り。はい。流れ、その辺の流れ、業界の流れについては興味があって、これらが どうやって実際の業務での開発に今後使われていくんだろうなと思いながらずっと見てはいます。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
おお ぎょ、業務への繋がりを
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
構成とかまだそんな決まってないと思うんで、それぞれが今実験して実験段階だと思うので、今後、今だってpages、pagesディレクトリーからappディレクトリになって、appディレクトリーどうやって使っていくんだろう。みたいな。ええ、そこの 話し方がまだ解決しないと。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
技術スタック、Next
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
ですね。僕が勉強したのが3年。はい、2年半ぐらい前なので、その時にはNext.jsがあったので。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そうですよね。うんうん
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
入りがNext.jsやったんで、結構Next.js周りに色々調べてるって感じです。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
ですよね。やっぱり今、今時はもう完全にNext.jsからこう、Reactに入るっていうのはしてる感じですよね。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
ドキュメントとか見ても、Reactのドキュメントにはないけど、Next.jsのドキュメントには結構詳しく書いてることの機能も色々詳しく書いてるとかあるんで、
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
Reactのドキュメント。あの、一応最近新しくなったんですよね。べーた、ベータが一時期。そう、そうなんですよね。確かにNext.jsのドキュメントの方が充実してるっていう時期はあります。
丸岡さんも同じ感じですか。僕は
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そうですね。僕はなんか、Vueだったり、VueとReactしか、その、ウェブフロントのフレームワーク触ってないんですけど、 なんか特にこう、どっちが好き。みたいな、どこだわりというか、どっちもいいなって僕は思ってるんですけど。そうですね、なんか直近だと、あ、なんかそういうフレームワークとかっていうよりは、なんかそもそものウェブapiというか、ちょっとなんかダイアログとかを実装する機会があって、例えばダイアログエレメントみたいな部分とか、そのアクセシビリティとかもちょっと対応したりして、なんかそういう、そもそもウェブapiを
なんか活用するみたいなの、結構大事だなと思って、なんか結構、知らないプロパティとかメソッドとか全然あったりするんで、調べてると、そういう部分も、こう、活かしきれてないなというか、 それを結構感じることが多くて、そのあたり、ちゃんと勉強しないとなっていうのは、はい、思ってます。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そういや、本当に、なんか結構、フレームワークって体系的に勉強する機会があると思うんですけど、その、なんですかね、ウェブapiというか、DOMというか、まあ、そ、そこらへんの知識って、 ま、大体MDNはを見てっていう感じになってしまって、結構知らないepiとか いっぱい出てきますよね。すごい。めっちゃそこらへんはそう。私も全然調べて知らなかったこととかも出てくるんで、すごい楽しいですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
奥、奥深いですね。のプラットホーム
この前、実は、えっと、この、新卒3人でちょっとイベントループ理解しようみたいな会をしたんですけど、なんかそれも、 MDNを調べながら、あの、実際にノードで何かを実装して、じゃ、これならどう動くかみたいなことを確認したしながら、えっと、調査したんですけど、結構面白かったです。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
おもろいね。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
難しいけど
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
色々。うん。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
イベントル周りどっちが優先順位。トラックでもうマイクロス。マイクロ
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
マイクロタスク。マクロタスクで。そうそうそうそう。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
それって、あの、なんか、自主的にというか。そうです。自然にそう。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
僕が結構なんか 業務で書いてるコードで、リクエストアニメーションフレームを使ってるとこがあって、はいはい、これなんだ。と思って、はい、リクエストアニメーションフレームの理解ができてなくて、で、調べてると、 あ、イベントループ確かに聞いたことあると思って、ちゃんと全然理解できてないなと思って、2人に聞いて、
じゃあ、でも2人ともテオはある程度は知ってたけど、あ、でも確かにあんまわかんないねって言っても、3人で
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
全然ふわふわだったので、なんかとてもいい機会だったと思います。
3人でホワイトボードにほんとにおおコールスタックとかを書きながら
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
調べて、ここに入ってみたいな。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
いやもうそれ多分むしろ、あの、今の社員、あの、現役社員とかもめっちゃ気になると思うんで、あの話とかをする機会を が作れればいいかもしれないですね。いや、それは聞きたかった。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
ちゃんとまとまってるわけじゃないですけど、
なにがわからんかが分かった段階で終わる で、それ持って帰っても、自分でそういうjsconfとかの動画めっちゃ再生されてるやつがあるんで、 それを見ながら、うん、理解して、そういう感じのが大事です。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
めちゃくちゃ大事です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
どのフレームワークでも裏では同じプラットフォームを使ってるので、その根本知識1番
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
では、えっとー、じゃあ、次のトピックにいこうと思います。えっと、今までの、まー、今までの、なんて言うんですかね、興味とか、ま、これまでやってきたことっていうところメインだったんですけれども、次からは、えっとー、これからやりたいことみたいなのを聞いてみようと思います。で、 これからやりたいことっていうのは、ま、単に、その、なんていうんすかね、こういう仕事がやりたいっていうのでもいいですし、あのー、ま、技術的な、こういう
ところにもっと深入りしたいとか、それ以外にも、まー、なんかこう、なんていうんですかね、将来のロールとか、そういったところでも全然構わないんで、ふわっとした話になるかなとは思うんですけれども、ちょっと聞いてみようかなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
行きます。そうですね、なんか、オープンソースにもっと関わりたいなっていう気持ちがずっと前からあって、 すごいSvelteのお世話になった気がしてて、それで、あ、もっとOSSに貢献したいなとずっと思ってたんですけど、 えっと、今年の2月に、えっと、社内のイベントがあって、オープンソーススプリントっていうイベントだったんですけど、えっと、そのイベントで、社内の
Node.jsのコントリビューターの元で頑張ってNode.jsにコントリビュートしよう。みたいなプロジェクトだったんですけど、それがめちゃめちゃ楽しくて、その、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ようやく
Node.jsへのPRがマージされた達成感が半端なかったので、これからも、 ま、仕事でも個人開発でも、オープンソースに貢献できたら最高だなって思います。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
それはSvelte関係なくですか。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
そうですね、まあ、Svelte、 あの、正直に言うと、その、Vercelのファンディングが入って、それで、フルタイム、えっと、Svelteの開発がやっている人が、えっと、3人になっていて、 それで、多分一般人ができるイシューまあまあの、減ったと思います。なるほど。なんかそこまで貢献できる機会、
もしかしたらないと思います。全然Svelteじゃなくても、毎日色々のオープンソースの、えっと、お世話になってるので、 そこに貢献できたらいいと思います。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
確かにOSSは あれですよね、こう、貢献、あの、フルタイムに入っているところとか、結構とっつきづらいっていうよりは、なんかまあ、やることがないみたいなのがあるし、逆になんかやること多すぎて なんもどうにもならないみたいなところ
あったりするっていう。ま、プロジェクトによるとは確かに、いや、思うんですけど、Node.js、確かに、あのー、すごいそういう、なんていうんですか、 ファーストコントリビュートをする人を増やそうみたいなのは、いや、めっちゃ感じますよね。私も多分似たような取り組みで、1回だけですけど、多分、すごい細かいところを直したりとかっていうのはやったことがあって いいですよね。Node.jsのそういう取り組みはめっちゃいいと思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
あの技術、洗練されすぎても細かいところしか直せないです。ノードは
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そうですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
でも、細かい修正でも、なんか何千万人が使ってるって思ったら、なんか全然達成感はあると思います。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
僕はこれがやりたいことは、開発もそうなんですけど、と一緒に企画みたいなことを同時にできるような、グロースエンジニアって呼ばれるんですけど、グロースエンジニア的な立ち回りが できるようになりたいです。うん まま、現状のチーム立場とかでも、企画の人と一緒に話し合ったり、ま、そういう機会はあるんですが、今んとこまだドメイン知識とか、そもそもの技術力が
足りなさすぎて、あんまこう、自分から提案とかがまだできてないんですよね。で、まだそういった話し合いにあんま参加できてないので、とりあえず一刻も早く会議に 参加できる、全力でいろんな知識を吸収してる最中なので、少なくとも1年以内には頑張って参加したいな。グロースエンジニア的な立ち回りしたいなと思いながら日々努力してます。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
結構珍しいですよね、
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
うちのチーム結構そういう人。多い
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
あー確かに。うんうん。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
スキマニチーム。結構そういう企画にも興味ある人が多いという人が集まってるようなイメージがあります。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
それはいいですよね。お互いになんか興味ないよりは絶対いいです。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ボトムアップな過程になってるってことですか。なんか誰か開発者が新しい アイデアがあったら、それ全然企画チームも取り組んでくれるみたいな
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
そうです。もうどっちかってエンジニアの意見が聞きたいっていうような企画の人が多いっていう感じですかね。
あ、結構毎朝朝やってて、そこでエンジニアと一緒に話し合ったりもするしっていう、結構毎日そういうわけで、結構そういう立ち回りはできるんじゃないかなと思ってます。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
じゃあ、あの、具体的なあの施策とか、そういう企画とかも、こう提案して出てくることとか。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
そうですそうです。そういうことが、先輩とかで1個出して、それが本流に。じゃ、こういうものを開発していこうっていう、ちゃんとエンジニア初の企画が同一だったこともあるっていう。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
それはあれですね。なんかチームに興味が出てきましたね。そう。いいです。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
うん。元々多分こういうことがしたいって言ってたので、そういうチームに配属されたのかな。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
あ、なるほどなるほど。思ってます。それはいいですね。はい。じゃあさ、あの、すごい希望とかは最初に 聞かれたんですかね。こう、こういう仕事をしてみたい、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
なんか、一応、配属アンケートみたいなのがあって、はい、 LINEに入って、どういうことをしていきたいかとか。うん、ま、それに限らず、ま、どういうエンジ、エンジニアというか、どういうキャリアを積みたいかみたいなアンケートあって、 多分、それを汲んでいただいてっていう感じです。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
あ、それ通りに配属された感じだと思ってます。あ、なるほどなるほど。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
たまたま、あの、研修期間、隣に、えっと、今の上司が座っていて、えー、で、なんか、その上司に色々と聞いたら、なんか、 LIFFアプリの開発してるみたいなことを言ってくれて。
で、LINEでしかそのLIFFアップのアプリの開発できないなと思って、LINEならでの開発したいなって思って。えっと、 多分その希望でチームに入ったと思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
自分が関わってるプロダクト、生で見るのが めちゃめちゃ楽しいです。例えば、このショップカードとか、そのお店が使っているショップカードを見たら、あ、このこのボタンの余白、僕が
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
それは確かに ここのここの色、私がつけました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
説明しやすいですね。なんか周りの人は技術じゃない人に説明できますから。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
家族とかね、確かに ギフトとか、あ、そうね、ギフトとか、まさに友達もみんな使ってるし、みたいな、私が使ったやりやすいやり、
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
フロントエンド、確かに、その、それ重視の人も結構、確かにそうですよね。
あの、この画面作ったっていうのは、めっちゃ言いやすい。い、いや、いやすい。丸岡さんは、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
あ、これからやりたいことみたいな、僕もなんかテオと一緒というか、その、OSSに、その、コントリビュートしたいっていうのすごい思ってて、 あんまりこう、今まで インターンとかそういうところでしかしてなかったんで、開発を、なんかそういう機会があまりなくて、で、結構こう、LINEのなんか先輩だったり見てると、なんか、業務上とかでも、
ちょっとこう、プルリク出したりみたいな、ま、こういうとこ、なんか改善したいよねみたいな部分で、ぼって出してるの、めっちゃかっこいいなと思って。
で、あ、そもそも、ま、なんて言うんですかね、ま、普段お世話になってる部分を還元したいっていう気持ちもありつつ、気軽にこう改善したいなみたいな時に、 プルリクを出せるぐらい、ま、理解度を深めたいみたいな部分もありつつ、っていう感じですね、うん。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
あとは、働き方みたいな部分だと、働きやすい人になりたいなってめっちゃ思います。コミュニケーション取りやすかったりとか、なんか、レス早かったりみたい。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
あ、はいはい。部分で、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
ドメイン知識とかも多分今足りてない部分あって、ま、その辺ちょっとこれからだなって思うんですけど、働きやすい人になりたいなっていう。はい、 思ってます。はい、
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そんな感じです。ありがとうございます。 結構、あの、その、最初のきっかけとかも、なんか、その、ソースコードよ、読みながらっていう話が、はい、出てたと思うんで、結構、多分、個人的にはもうすぐ出せそうな、雰囲気はいい 感じはするんですけど。
ま、でも、実際、多分、嬉しいと思う人が大半だと思うんですよ。うん、リクエスト出してくれたら、う、ちなみに、ど、どんな。 OSS。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
はい。興味。あ、そうですね。なんかこれがいいみたいな ていうよりは、こう、自分がこう例えば使ってて、なんかここ、ちょっとこういう機能もあったらいいよねみたいな部分で 出せればいいな。そこにこだわりが。は特にない。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
なるほどなるほど。使ってる目線で。そうですね。それは大事です。
やっぱり。つか、使ってないライブラリの。うん。OSSコントリビュート。ちょっと。モチベーションを持たないと思うんで。ありがとうございます。
なんかお互いに質問とか追加のあります。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
多分、あの、ブロックチェーンなんかから生えたと思いますけど、その、今でもシーとかで開発したいと
とかって思ったりします。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
あー、いや、そこの、なんだろう。例えば使ってる言語だったり、そこにこだわりがあるというよりは、どっちかって言うと、その当時は そもそもビットコインどうなってんの。みたいな部分に興味があったから、今なんかこう、 それこそシープラで開発したいみたいな、そういう気持ちがあるって感じではないかもしれない。なんか、作るものの方に今はこ
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ものが大事です。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
それは私も同感です。はい、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そうです。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
それでも、なんか別の言語で開発すると、
あ、こういうパターンもあ、ある
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
だなってなります。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
研修。研修の。そう、それはすごい。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
研修の間に、その、androidアプリ開発。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
はいはいはいはいはい。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
技術者全員でやっていて、基本的にKotlinかReact Nativeとかの技術スタックになると思いますけど、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
僕とそのテオがそのKotlinで、Jetpack Composeとかを使ってクライアントを書いてたりしてて、 確かにその時に、そうですね。なんか思想とか、ま、そもそも多分領域が違うんで、ま、ネイティブにしかない要素とかも結構あったりするんで、そこは元々違いますけど、確かにモデルが違うなみたいな部分は思いました。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
やっぱりandroidアプリで新卒研修は健在なんですね。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
あれは、例年なんですか。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
ええ、ですよね。私もなんかLINEクローンを作りましょうみたいな。多分一緒。一緒です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
素晴らしい機会だと、
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
確かに触ったことなかった。うんうんうん。
ここはめっちゃReact Nativeだ。はいはいはい。
まただ。React Nativeで書いたことなかったし、その開発体験とかがあんまわかってなかったので、色々学べることたくさんありました。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
Reactと言っても結構違いますよね。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
違うなと思いました。うん。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
HTML要素がなかったっけ。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
元々提供されているUIコンポーネントを。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そう、多分、React Nativeでしてる。あ、そっか、ものが提供されてる、
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
すごい書き方はちょっと、とか、すごいなと思いながら書いてました。ただ、その書き方が、今も言ってたネイティブアプリみたいな作ってるんで、
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
近いな、ですよね。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
同じことやってるなと。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
まあ、確かにそう。うん、まあ、ネイティブアプリという縛りがある時点で技術タック変わってくるんで、そこらへんは、ですよね、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ちょっと恥ずかしいですけど、その、ずっと、アプリの中にデータベースが入るの知らなくて、で、なんか、web開発だと、まあ、その、 ローカルストレージとか使う機会はあると思いますけど、まさに、いやまさか、なんか、えっと、SQLiteとかが裏で走ってるって思いませんでした。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
この違和感とか、こう、逆にローカルで持ってた方がパフォーマンスも良くなるしっていう。持ちすぎ。持ちすぎというか、ウェブと考え方違って、そこはなんか新鮮でした。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
映像キャッシュみたいな感じだよ。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そう。LINEとかまさにそうそう。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
その同期とか難しかったね。バックエンドと。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そうです。データの整合性を
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
データベースの同期、なるほどなるほど。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
タイムのチャットの
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
構築にするだとか。ま、本当にあれ。みたいな感じ。
いや、パスタが食えるみたいなので。うんうんうん。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
フロントエンド。確かに。なんかもうなければ取ってくるみたいな感じになってますけど、確かに。ま、大体今だとなんかタンスタッククエリーとかで、クエクエリーのライブラリーで任せみたいなんですけど、そこらへんとかも結構違って
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Kotlinよりは。うん。grpcっていうライブラリを、
今ウェブ開発でもあのtrpcとか流行っているので、そこはなんか似ていそうですね。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
React Nativeとgrpcの相性悪くて使えんかったんで、
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
ウェブソケットで。ソケットであったそう。使いたかった。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
今私も5年目なんですけれど、今やったらやっぱり違う感じになってそう。結構面白そ。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
確かに使う技術が
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
なに使われます。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
いや、でもあのスキマニのあのCapacitorの話とか聞いてるんで、Capacitorやってみたい気持ちはありますね。
React Nativeは一昔前はちょっと触ってた っていう感じだったんですけど、そうですね、今はそこらへんとか。Flutterもまあちょっと興味ある。いや、でもCapacitorの方がなんか楽しそうだなっていうところがある開発です。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
Jetpack Composeも多分かなり新しい。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
そうね。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
あれも本当になんか宣言的UIというか。うん、なんかReactみたいな。そうですね。
作られたフロントエンドのエンジニアがすごい馴染みやすい感じでしたね。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
今、外。あのネイティブアプリ楽しそうかもしれない。ちょっと。そう、androidアプリ。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
みんなで。
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
あの、研修として。すごい。そこの壁が。確かにね。
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
そう。1回作ってみて
NOTE Speaker: itatchi3
ハードルめっちゃ下がってる。確かに
NOTE Speaker: maruoka.kento
良かったですね。研修として。すごい。よかった。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
じゃあ結構。じゃ、もう45分ぐらいな。 では閉めようかなと思います。はい。今回は、えーっと、2023年卒 新卒フロントエンドエンジニアにえー話を聞いていきました。
LINEのフロントエンド組織UITでは、このような技術的なキャッチアップをひ日々行っております。えー、このエピソード を聞いて、何かご意見やご感想ありましたらいつでもえーツイートしてください。#UIT_INSIDEでえ。ぜひツイートしてください。 それではありがとうございました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ありがとうございました。